good morning believe nation today's
message is practice over to you Bruno
Mars any young aspiring musicians out
there if music is what you want to do if
music is what you love and your passion
it doesn't take a fragrance it's not
about the tabloids it's about you
putting in the work practicing every day
practicing your vocals practicing your
instrument practicing songwriting and
hopefully one day you write the song you
know the whole world wants to get down
to and I promise you I promise you one
day you're gonna have your moment to
shine and you're gonna have a lot of
people saying that you can't do it and
you're not good enough but I promise you
if you go out there and you sing and you
put your heart and soul into it and you
follow your dream one day you're gonna
be sitting next to Ellen DeGeneres
so that was a next-level clip haha the
question of the day today is I'm curious
to know how do you practice in your
business for me it's a YouTube channel
and practicing every single day making
videos every time I do a video I'm
practicing for the next video for my
next interview for my next speech and
that's why I've been so consistent in
making thousands of videos on this
channel so that one day when I get the
call to go to Ellen I'm gonna be ready
because I've put in the hustle in the
practice so what do you do to practice
how do you hone your craft how do you
get better at what you're doing leave in
the comments below I'm gonna join in the
discussion thank you guys so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events presa